l'ambassadeur ukrainien auprès des
nations unies est en train d instruments
il est alarmant que plusieurs employés
responsables de la sécurité sur le site
nucléaire ont selon les sources étaient
tués par à des russes il n'y a pas eu de
rotation du personnel depuis hier matin
le bâtiment de l'unité une le principal
bâtiment a été endommagé
le pont sur le rhin autre bâtiment a été
abîmée la connexion à
l'effet que téléphonique est il perturbé
voilà l'état des unités l'unité numéro
numéro 1 est en panne le principal
bâtiment est endommagée lors pas sur le
bâtiment principal et endommagé l'unité
2 quant à del et l'unité 3 ont été
déconnectés du réseau et le
refroidissement des installations
nucléaires est en charge et henry est en
cours à l'unité numéro 4 6 190 mégawatts
de puissance unités 5 et 6 ont été
refroidis les inspecteurs nationaux du
la sûreté nucléaire ukrainienne ne sont
pas autorisés à
contrôler ses sites
il n'y a pas eu de modification du
niveau de radiation les données des
systèmes de suivi des radios radiations
ne fonctionne pas
refroidissement du combustible nucléaire
a par ailleurs
maintenu grâce à des systèmes
électriques conformément aux exigences
des réglementations techniques pour
l'opération pour l'exploitation sûre de
la centrale si à un moment ou à un autre
le processus de refroidissement est
perturbé cela pourrait entraîner des
dégâts radioactifs sur une heure sur un
grand territoire et entraîner des
conséquences irréparables pour
l'environnement de tout le continent
deux personnes y compris des civils a
qui sont actuellement dans l'incapacité
de fuir la zone autour de du site à
cause des bombardements et des combats
seraient impactés
pour reprendre les mensonges de
l'ambassadeur de russie sur les
étudiants on voit que c'est une
technique pour détourner l'attention
c'est un exemple de ce que l'ambassadeur
a souhaité proposer comme un message à
angélique de paix
mais je tiens à lui rappelé et à nous
rappeler à toutes et à tous
satan était également un an
un ange qui s'est rebellé contre
1,6 j'aimerais demander au représentant
permanent de la fédération de russie
s'il est toujours en mesure de comptes
de communiquer avec ce capital
peut-être le cas peut-être pas qui c'est
envoyez leur un appel envoyé un appel
aux forces armées afin d'assurer un
couloir sur de permettre aux étudiants
étrangers de quitter l les zones à
problèmes arrêter de diffuser des
mensonges
et vous savez très bien ce qui se passe
sur le terrain si vous êtes réellement
en contact avec votre capital
[Musique]
les conséquences d'une catastrophe
nucléaire de cette ampleur est en pleine
ampleur
pourrait dépasser tous les accidents et
du passé y compris de tchernobyl et
fukushima
la russie a délibérément entrepris une à
attaques armées sur un site nucléaire un
acte qui viole tous les accords
internationaux
dans le cadre de la loi en particulier
la charte de l'onu à la convention
conjointe sur la sécurité de la gestion
des combustibles usés et la sécurité de
la gestion des déchets nucléaires la
convention sur les accidents sur la
prévention des coups sur les alertes des
accidents nucléaires et la convention
sur la protection des infrastructures
nucléaires et des équipements nucléaires
le bombardement de zappeurs reejer bien
centrales nucléaires deux appareils a
été également une classe violation de la
convention sur la non prolifération des
armes nucléaires et de la convention sur
la prévention du terrorisme nucléaire
nous sommes déçus par la réaction de
l'aiea dont la déclaration n'est pas
allé aussi loin et n'a pas inclus inclut
des mentions des attaques sur ses sites
nous demandons à une action claire et
décisive de la part de lio
la communauté internationale doit
répondre à la hauteur des actions de la
fédération de russie qui pourrait
entraîner une catastrophe nucléaire sans
précédent toutes les forces armées
russes doivent se retirer de la centrale
nucléaire
aujourd'hui j'ai envoyé une lettre au
président du conseil de sécurité pour
lui rappeler la décision du conseil sur
l'ex la zone d'exclusion aérienne lors
de précédents conflits afin d'éviter
davantage de victimes chez les civils
afin de protéger les populations civiles
data de bombardements aériens y compris
le personnel humanitaire
qui doit avoir un accès
afin de permettre une évacuation des
civils à cet égard nous avons nous
demande dont nous vous demandons de vous
intéresser à la question de la sécurité
des infrastructures critiques et des
installations nucléaires en ukraine il
est urgent de parler d'une interdiction
de tous les vols dans l'espace aérien de
l'ue prenne cela doit être notre
priorité absolue pour le conseil de
sécurité
nous aimerions également rappelé que
l'ukraine le 13 mars le 30 mars 2015 a
demandé le déploiement d'une opération
de maintien de la paix de sécurité dans
les territoires du kenya le document
s2000 à gaz
avec les modalités spécifiques à le
définir en consultation avec le site
ukrainien
en tenant compte que les forces armées
russes ne pouvait pas faire partie du
contingent de laquelle la paix car c'est
l'occupation défense armée qui doit être
réparé afin de maintenir un cessez le
feu et de maintenir la paix
si le conseil de sécurité n'agit pas
et bien ce serait une
responsabilité ce serait sa
responsabilité qui sera en jeu ainsi que
celle de toute l'organisation
chers membres du conseil de sécurité
je me dois de demander au
secrétaire
général adjoint porter une demande à
monsieur terrestre sur les terres
général à s'assurer que chaque organe
des nations unies
chaque collaborateur du secrétariat
respecte la décision de l'assemblée
générale du 2 mars
[Musique]
et ne dévie pas ou ne n'ajoute pas
d'ambiguïté ou de fausses informations
comme l'expliquent utilisation du terme
forces d'opérations spéciales dans la
résolution
c'est une agression contre l'ukraine
une semaine d' invasion russe a déjà
entraîné des milliers de victimes
plus d'un million de réfugiés
et des infrastructures dévastées
il est du devoir de la communauté
internationale de mettre un terme aux
actes terroristes de l'uck de la russie
mettre un terme à ces actions arrêtées
de soute
continuer à soutenir l'ukraine
exclure la russie des institutions
internationales car la russie ne mérite
pas de siéger au sein d'une organisation
constituée de civilisation d'une société
civilisée einstein a déclaré que le
monde ne sera pas détruit par ceux qui
font le mal
les ukrainiens géreront le mal
mais parce qu'il voit le mal se propager
sans rien faire
le peuple ukrainien fait tout ce qui est
en son pouvoir fait plus que tout il se
sacrifie sac fait le sacrifice ultime
et malheureusement et c'est une honte on
voit encore une poignée de personnes
autour de nous ou parmi nous
qui restent les bras croisés
agissez dès aujourd'hui où il sera
peut-être trop tard non seulement pour
l'ukraine mais pour vous tous merci
voilà on vient d'entendre en direct
l'ambassadeur ukrainien auprès des
nations unies